[Music]
there's so many great tools that
stanford provides to connect these
people
just the diversity in terms of career
and top-tier talent
you have the opportunity to reach out
and start a relationship with people
around the world who are working at some
of the top companies in the world
the format is different but i actually
think it's a little bit more powerful
because you have almost an unlimited
network of people
and you can connect to not only people
who are going to school with you
but people who have completed the
program who are still part of the
community base
programs like these connect people who i
think often want to change the world
they want to leave a positive impact in
the world and make it a better place
i had a question about strategy i've had
a question about
marketing there's so much talent on that
network that you can tap into
it's about taking those frameworks and
now that you have the opportunity to
apply them
you can get engaged that network
connecting
online can be deepened so much as
as we experience this program in terms
of what kind of connection that we made
you would have a further communication
even after finishing that course you
would have a dialogue
catching up with people you have this
sort of a very strong connection
you feel like you've met that person
like so many times
it's one of the most valuable part of
this program
that you can build such a strong
connection throughout this
the lead program had really changed my
life i wouldn't exaggerate that
but that's definitely for sure what you
get on the fly
is really some invaluable extra points
that is multicultural know-how you get
to know people from all over the world
all their
interesting stories the connections you
gain in the leap program
are invaluable because they are
life-changing you have widened your
personal contacts
your personal network on a basis
that i have never expected and it is
the impact it has on your business life
challenging
each other and motivating each other to
continue to learn and to continue to
proceed
it is based on educational content
that's right that's the foundation of it
but it comes to life through the
connections and through the community